one of the things because I love your
book and I've been pouring over it
certain things I picked out I wanted to
ask you about like I thought it was so
interesting and also so educational that
you really were a part of like the
evolution of social media through
politics what do you advise on how to
use social media to the benefit of how
we further things along just for
Humanity well because my views are kind
of different than many others
uh we have a hard time
getting through in the corporate media
right the corporate media you know is
owned by very very wealthy people often
don't want to hear what we have to say
for the working class of this country so
with social media during my campaigns
was very important is we could talk
directly so if we held a rally in Iowa
okay and you had 2 000 people coming up
well that's fine but you have 200 000
people watching it on television and
then they would say oh my goodness these
ideas are not so crazy I agree with them
so we could talk directly to millions of
people and that to me was very very
effective what do you think is like
different about this generation who so
gets that because I do think through
social media young people are so much
more educated about things and and
passionate like do you think it's that
what's the generational shift because
when I was a kid I don't think everyone
was excited about rallying the youth and
now I think they're putting a lot of
their Stakes into it well I think what
has happened and it's you know somebody
has had the opportunity to go all over
this country I've been in every state in
the country and what you find is this
and we should all be very excited about
this and feel good about it the younger
generation to my mind
is the most anti-racist generation
anti-sexist Generation anti-homophobic
generation the most compassionate
generation in my lifetime
and there are millions of young people
who want to do everything they can to
bring Justice to this country and to
work together to do that so I think we
should all be as Americans very proud of
this generation yes and all that they
are doing yes I agree they were not like
you're not like that when I was growing
up and then another fact about you is
you are and have been in some movies
not quite your movie Korea but I
yes well will you play our favorite game
behind the scenes with us sure ladies
and gentlemen behind
[Applause]
the sweetheart sweethearts dance from
1988 about an estranged couple it stars
John Johnson Susan Sarandon and Jeff
Daniels and apparently this guy is in
the movie well at the time I was mayor
of the City of Burlington and they came
to our community to make the film and I
got dragged into it with Don Johnson and
there was that was my movie career well
but then hold on a second because you
got a big Talking part my
ex-girlfriend's wedding receiver
families four people in America from
about an Italian Jewish wedding well I
want to ask you you know you're a movie
person what do you think do you think I
have a career I think you're so natural
like it I just you're you know you're
being very authentic very you I could
see you as an actor I don't see that
sort of like fake put on I think you're
really good at it all right so when my
political career is over
you and me
and by the way I love the book Bernie so
much now I'm like oh Bernie I just love
this book Bernie's book it's okay to be
angry about capitalism
the easiest way to prep a wedge all
right let's find out thank you so much
[Music]
thank you